we will get acquainted with the
different domains of bioinformatics and
learn more about the omics studies and
technologies
my name is sunali khari and i am the
omixlogic community manager responsible
for daily interaction with thousands of
users that are a part of a
bioinformatics community managed by pine
biotech
omixlogic is an international program
that is running in five different
regions with over 10 000 users around
the world due to this fast growth our
team is working with local and regional
coordinators that are helping refine
local program logistics and leverage our
online training resources adapting them
to the needs of the students and
researchers around the world
our training is designed to allow
participants to apply methods to curated
and new data sets and develop
independent projects that showcase what
has been learned in the context of a
personal portfolio of projects and as a
result anyone starting on this
journey in bioinformatics can start
developing a project of their own
in fact we have already worked with many
students who have completed this kind of
training and developed interesting
research projects that won awards and
got published in peer-reviewed uh
journals
and today in this workshop you will be
given the directions to access the t
bioinfo platform for bioinformatics
processing and analysis of
transcriptomics data the platform
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management and analysis cloud
infrastructure to run bioinformatics
pipelines different stages of analysis
are performed in different sections uh
on this multi-omics platform the team
iron info platform is built to help
prepare biologists and clinicians for
the large multi-omics data sets they
have to deal with on their own without
relying on technical support to set up
computational environments and pipelines
for processing
the simple to use solution can help
train and prepare anyone with a
biological data set for advanced
computational analysis visualization and
annotation
to learn more or try the tbi info
platform you can register yourself for a
free demo account and connect with one
of our representatives
i also want to share with you that we
have an upcoming comics research
symposium that we would talk we would be
talking about in more detail the virtual
research symposium is an opportunity for
students faculty and companies to come
together and discuss advances in
bioinformatics
in this session speakers will highlight
advanced new areas for bioinformatics as
a discipline or for students and faculty
insights into best practices for
mastering bioinformatics skills and
allow them to explore career
opportunities in academia and industry
we will cover bioinformatics as cutting
edge research and applications for
undergraduate masters and phd programs
in bioinformatics we we will also have
recruiters industry internships and uh
talk more about job opportunities
effective resources for training and
education and we have amazing prizes for
best school college and citizen research
projects as well
now to discuss more about the workshop
and also about the symposium i would
like to pass it on to ceo pine biotech
ilya brodsky over to yuwilia
thank you so much and welcome everyone
to today's webinar i'm glad that you are
able to join
and what i would like to start with
today is to briefly discuss what are
some of the challenges and opportunities
in this domain because
as we all hear there are huge
opportunities with novel technologies
with precise data in all of these
different areas i mean we all heard
about the revolutions with
mrna vaccines crispr genomic
surveillance single cell data
all of these also come with
computational technologies like the
growth and artificial intelligence and
machine learning quantum computing high
performance computing cloud technologies
as well as big data and integration
so
many of the people that come from the
life science background from biology
from clinical background from
biochemistry
when we hear about these advances in
computational technologies there is a
gap that prevents us from directly using
a lot of those techniques
because it requires engineering skills
or data analysis skills and that
gap creates a lag behind the growth and
the amount of data and the quality of
data
and the information the actionable
information and the insights that this
information can provide us with to
actually do something in the fields of
biology medicine biotechnology and
agriculture in fact in a survey in 2017
there was a question about which step of
one of those techniques or an asic was
the most intimidating sorry
and the answer was that the majority of
the people struggled with the analysis
of this data right so as you can see 49
of the responders
said that analysis of rna-seq data was
the most intimidating step
and one of the things that we realized
as we started dealing with a lot of
people interested in bioinformatics is
that there's a whole range of
prerequisites that students oftentimes
face before they can even get started
and there's also a lot of hands-on
experience that you need to acquire as
you're trying to analyze different types
of data which makes it also difficult to
analyze larger data sets because on your
laptop on your computer oftentimes
without great access to internet large
storage a lot of processing and ram
power you just cannot analyze a lot of
these newer types of data that are
coming out
so that's why what our team did is we
decided to build a community to address
this challenge
first of all this community
is to provide training in bioinformatics
it is also to bring together experts and
those who are passionate about
data-driven research and data analysis
and the objective is to really enable
students clinicians and faculty with
without the engineering background
without the technical skills to be able
to
leverage these large data sets and apply
analytical tools to complex data
now we realize that this gap doesn't
appear by
itself it's a problem that a lot of
universities colleges and other research
institutions are trying to address
and the gap that is created
at the university at these places of
learning learning
creates confusion because on one side
you get excellent training in technical
skills
and you probably have some expertise at
the end of receiving your degree but at
the same time
there's a confusion about how does this
actually work how do i actually manage
to use these tools effectively myself
without having that practical experience
and so to address that gap we started
putting together the pieces
the big data analysis infrastructure
a network of experts that can assist and
help and mentor and guide students that
are interested in this as well as our
training and research support
infrastructure so to show you how it all
works
i would like to showcase
one of the
central pieces where we tried to connect
all of these things together the
omixlogic portal so if you could please
go with me to the omixlogic portal
if uh sonica could please post the links
in the chat
so on this portal
first of all let's take a look at the
home page you will see here all of the
different pieces organized together so
it's a free registration everybody can
register today
the way you can register is click right
here on this button register for free
and you will be taken to a page where
you can register yourself
using your email or one of the social
media account now if you don't have an
account you click right here create an
account
i'm going to give it just a few minutes
for everybody to go through the
registration
after you have registered yourself
please put number one in the chat so
that we know that you are registered
and i'll go back to the home page and
just wait for all of you
to let me know that you arrested
all right
thank you very much
all right great
okay so i see
quite a number of you have already
registered so thank you for putting that
there so
let's take a look at
what
is the omixlogic portal
the onyx logic portal seeks to bring
together everything that you need to get
started and grow this is relevant for
students as well as for faculty and
today i will demonstrate how
first piece
is that we realize that those coming
from a life science background are
interested in bioinformatics primarily
because it is a way to address
interesting projects
that are at the cutting edge of oncology
research infectious diseases
neuroscience and agriculture these are
the
precision medicine precision agriculture
novel interventions novel therapeutics
novel diagnostic methods so these
methods rely heavily on data the data is
complex
and the data can reveal important
insights to drive each one of these
fields forward
so that's why according to these
different types of projects we created a
case study driven
approach to understand the value of
omics data
and practical
steps to analyze this data first of all
understanding the logic of the analysis
and then
also acquiring practical technical
skills that if you are
if you decide to go that route you can
master right here on the portal
a
critical piece of this experience
is the t-bio info platform
the t-bio info platform is a place where
you can analyze integrate
visualize multi-omics data okay so once
you have created your accounts
in 24 hours after your account has been
created you will be granted a demo
account on the tbi info server okay so
to demonstrate what the server is going
to be useful for
you can click right here
now if you already had an account for a
while with us on rmxlogic you will be
able to log in here as well
if you don't have the access just yet
you will have to wait for 24 hours
before that account is generated
and in any case after you've created a
free account on the onyx logic portal
you will have
a demo
account here which is very useful for
education now i'm going to demonstrate
to you today how
so and thank you jesse for posting the
link so on this link
you will find
a in areas of analysis section now
there's a lot of different types of
omics data and there's a lot of things
that you can do with this data but let's
start with some of the basics let's
understand just two examples of what you
can do here without any coding and how
does this fit in to the omics logic
portal experience
so we'll take a look today at first of
all one of these sections so you can see
for next generation sequencing data
one of the data types is transcriptomic
data analysis and here right under this
rnac chip you can open up some demo
example projects that you can run right
here on the portal without having any
engineering or coding skills so an army
seek
pipeline typically contains several
different logical steps
if you click right here on start you'll
see those steps highlighted in different
colors
pre-processing which means cleaning up
the raw data that is produced by the
sequencer
mapping or trying to understand which
piece of the genome did the reed come
from
and then quantification
how much reeds do i have in each segment
or a gene or an exon
so that i can understand what are the
levels of gene expression
to understand how these pieces connect
together we can actually build a
pipeline which is just a series of
algorithms connected together to
understand what are the inputs and what
are the outputs
so after you
finish reading through this first pop-up
you can also open up the input files
and the output files okay and so here
you can click on ok
and now a limited selection of options
is highlighted based on your previous
selection so since we have a project
that we loaded in it's a project on the
transcriptomic
analysis of cell lines from different
types of breast cancer subtypes we now
have to pre-process or clean up the
reeds that came from the sequencer
to do that we can use
trim pneumatic which trims adapters from
each side of the reeds
and pcr clean that reduces the
artificial amplification based on pcr
bias
at the step of
bridge pcr amplification so to address
this challenge we have a special
algorithm called pcr clean
after we've cleaned up our raw data
remember we need to
map it on to the reference genome now
there's a lot of different options here
you can see that they're organized into
logical groups and within each group
there are several things that you can
compare so essentially you can benchmark
and compare how the different algorithms
perform and understand the inputs and
outputs for each one
so let's use the simple option we'll use
bow type 2 which is an algorithm that
provides us with capabilities to rapidly
map all of these reads to the reference
genome understand where they came from
and create a mapped file or a bam file
okay so now we're going to
connect this to our previous steps
and finally we have to quantify the ring
so what is quantification
ultimately we want some numbers these
numbers come from an abundance of reads
which are fairly short
on a long sequence maybe thousands of
nucleotides at a time
and to understand what is
that number that we need to assign
to the level of expression we need to
use a complex algorithm in this case
we're using
rna-seq expectation maximization or rsem
which actually assigns numbers in a few
different formats fpcam rpkm tpm or raw
read count
so in this case we're going to connect
rsem
to the end to complete our pipeline
and once this is completed you will
quickly see here some outputs that are
useful to understand what transcriptomic
data is all about so the transcriptomic
data
as you can see right here provides us
with an expression of exons an
expression of genes and an expression of
isoforms
expression of genes
are the 25 approximately 22 and a half
thousand genes that we have in the human
genome
each gene as you remember can is
combined from different exons different
combinations of exons so we can look at
all of our exons or we can see how those
exons are combined into actual
transcripts or isoforms of genes and so
we can download these tables and just
see what these tables look like and so
that is the first
important application of this t-violin
for platform right here without any
coding we were able to take some raw
data prepared for analysis analyze it
quantify it and produce a table of
expression
now the second question right as i
already said in the beginning as people
who come from a life science background
many of us are interested in different
types of projects where this technique
could be applied to
so that's why on the
learn portal if you go right here to the
courses tab
you will find
several projects that are used as case
studies to give us access to curated
data sets with an explanation of how
step by step we can go through those
transcriptomic analysis steps and get
some insights get some meaningful
understanding about the data
so let's take a look at one of these
i will open up
project number five
modeling
cancer precision medicine
this is a project
where the data came from so we
looked at a data set
this data set is explained right here in
this project i pasted the link inside
the chat
so the first thing that we can do is we
can go to this first
lesson and this lesson is by the way
free for anyone anyone that would like
to use
their portal to try it out you can see
all of this information that i'm showing
you
so
the project explains how patient-derived
cell lines that came from patients with
different subtypes of breast cancer
were used these cell lines were used to
generate multi-omics data
so that we could try and link signatures
in onyx data
with
another type of data which is
measurement of drug efficacy
the measurement of drug efficacy was
done with a
special way to quantify
how
a
cell line response how a cell culture
responds to treatment and that is called
ld50
so now we have signatures from the
transcriptomic data that we have to find
and based on those signatures we can
predict
which types of
treatments are going to be the best for
that patient
so as we go to our next step
we can read about what you can learn
from this case study
there are several different things that
you can learn first of all you can learn
about different types of data genomic
transcriptomic
and even the microbiome metagenomics so
you can analyze different types of omics
data
number two you can see the application
of machine learning
in this example because to understand
what signatures are specific to each
subtype of those breast cancer patients
we can use a classification model which
i will show you in just a few moments of
how you can train such a model right
there on the tbi info platform
but also you get exposed to a number of
concepts in precision medicine which go
to explain biomarker discovery
integration of multinomics data
essentially to make a decision a
clinical decision on how to treat a
patient with the best outcome for that
patient okay it's a model it's not a
real clinical project but nevertheless
it's a model that we can learn from
now to learn about the full publication
there's a
link right here in number three for
associated publication that describes
how the data was generated what were the
objectives and ultimately what did the
authors use to train their model
validate the results and propose an
algorithm that essentially could be used
in a clinical decision making scenario
so once you complete this step
you can click on next
and learn a little bit about how these
types of projects are applied in
modern precision medicine
kind of research in biomedical research
and what are some of the applications of
such projects as we are using today so
now we can complete the lesson we've
understood uh what is being uh done here
okay i think uh
to complete my name here
okay and this kind of feedback by the
way that you submit in the form is very
useful for us as we try to improve a lot
of the materials on the site
so after we've understood the data and
where it came from next we need to
analyze it and prepare it for machine
learning so what is machine learning
let's go back to this section for the t
by info platform
here we have processing pipelines right
these are pipelines designed to take raw
data and turn them into a structured
data the structured data typically is a
data frame or a table once we have that
table that contains many rows in our
case 22 500 rows because we have all of
the genes from the full transcriptome
based on these cell lines
and multiple samples in this case we
have 52 samples coming from the cell
line experiment
organized into multiple groups those
groups could be referred to as classes
one of the things that we can then do
right here on data integration and
modeling side is use
data mining approaches to extract
meaningful insights from this type of
data that we have
now there are two major areas that we
can apply here there's unsupervised
analysis and then there's supervised
analysis
before we jump into that let us download
the table that we generated in the
rna-seq data so i will go back here
and i will again repeat the steps for
this demo rna-seq cell line project and
that will help us understand again how
these steps fit into the final output
that we have
so we go from start again remember we
have three different steps
processing mapping and quantification of
expression now if you want to understand
how to connect them together this is an
example pipeline that you can see right
here
first we go to pre-processing which is
the blue
so we go from trim-o-matic trimming the
reeds from sequencing adapters
to pcr clean where we remove this
artificial and biased pcr amplification
then we have two options for mapping we
can either do complex mapping where we
are detecting exons and preparing our
own transcriptome or we can do simple
mapping where we just follow the
instructions in the existing gtf file
we'll take the simpler option today
and then we have to quantify the levels
of expression as i explained already a
lot of challenges with trying to figure
out how a certain profile of abundance
could be converted to a single number
that represents gene expression
and finally after we end
we can see the output files and we have
here several outputs
from all of these outputs let's take the
cell lines expression data normalized
and annotated we'll download this and we
will see
what is
in the file
okay so that we can see
what
this
could be used for when we talk about
machine learning now in addition to this
we can download this file cell lines
clinical subtypes and that will give us
a sense of what clinical
subtypes are represented
with these cell lines
okay so here
you can see that the names of the
columns
are names of cell lines
the names of the rows
are genes
nsg right those are genes
and we have about 7 000
because
this data was already cleaned up from
genes with zero expression and with low
expression in fact it was cleaned up for
expression under six
and then all of the data was normalized
so all of the data was prepared for
downstream analysis
in here we can see that for each name
each cell type name we have
right here a transcriptional subtype
which means a clinical
class that we can use
to
determine differences between different
subtypes of breast cancer okay and so
here you see you also have a basic
subtype and then what is the cell type
and all these cell types are breast
cancer cell line okay
so what can we do with this information
first of all if we just take
all of these
and we put them here
okay we're just going to see how many do
we have right so we're going to transfer
those
and let's go to the bottom
we can see
that
up until here it looks like what we have
exactly matches what we have in the
annotation okay
so we can just take the transcriptional
subtype
and we can create here
another row we'll call this row group
and we will put in here
this annotation
now for each one of our cell
line names we have
a
transcriptional
profile
let's save this
okay i'm going to save this cell line
expression data normalized and annotated
and the first thing that i would like to
do after i've done this is to understand
what is going on in my data what are
some of the major trends in my data
the way i can do this is i can go to
unsupervised analysis
upload my data
press on continue and use principle
component analysis now what is principal
component analysis and i'm sure that
many of you already know principal
component analysis and what it does but
for those of you that are maybe new to
this i will just briefly explain
principle component analysis
is an analysis of variance of all of the
data to maximize variance between
different samples in my data
and show us the major trends
based on all of the features without any
feature selection
using dimensionality reduction
what does that actually mean
when we look at our data we can
visualize
the variance between each one of our
samples using two dimensions so let's
take
these two dimensions right i can just
insert here a scatter plot using two
dimensions and i will get some cloud of
dots this cloud of dots represents all
of the samples that i have
based on two dimensions x and y
so here i have the x and here i have the
y
and that shows me some trends in my data
but i have close to 7 000 dimensions so
how can i translate
this data
into a simple visualization that will
show me what are the major trends
to do that there's a mathematical
technique that can deal with so many
dimensions in a way that we can't
visually
and the technique goes like this if i
have a complex shape
that shape has
variance it could be more stretched out
or more condensed
if i want to find those areas where it's
stretched out the directions where it's
stretched out i can make a projection
and use that projection to explain
variance okay so i can make a projection
use it as my axis
make another projection in the second
most variable direction and use that as
my second observation right and so i can
transform the 7 000 dimensions that i
have here
into just two dimensions and that's why
this method is called dimensionality
reduction
dimensionality reduction simply means
that i simplify the representation of
the data
to understand
variability
overall
so now we have the results of this
pipeline we ran pca and it produced for
us a plot a visual result that we can
understand
okay so let's take this let's take a
look at this visual result
what we can see
is that based on all of the data that we
loaded into the pipeline
there are two major groups that separate
the cell line information of all the
gene expression
and we can see down here the annotation
by group for example on this side we
have luminal
and on this side we have the rest
we have right here basal cloud and low
and
normal like so all of these are very
different from these
that is new information that we got from
analysis that we just performed but
there's some additional information here
for example we also see how much
variance does this explain and we can
see that together it is under 40 and
what that shows us is that this
particular data set has a lot of
additional noise
that does not clearly explain
all of the variability between these
subtypes
even though it does have some major
trends
an additional analysis that we can
perform under unsupervised analysis
section is called clustering
so let's try to do that together again
we will upload the data set this time
i am going to remove this annotation i
don't need the annotation for groups i'm
going to remove it
actually what i will do is i will
put it right here
i don't need necessarily to know
the names of my samples i want to
understand what groups can clustering
put all of this information in based on
my clinical annotation okay and i will
just save it again
let's upload this data right here
continue
okay
process all right and now we will
perform clustering so you can see that
the first section is visualization just
visually want to understand what's going
on the second section is called
clustering so clustering helps us
identify
specific groups of data but also define
the relationship between them so that we
can understand
in greater granularity what groups are
found in this data overall so the way to
do this is to use something like
hierarchical clustering
with linkage right here we have linkage
called war d2 so we will change it to
that
we'll use euclidean distance again if
you kind of imagine this cloud of dots
we can just measure distance between
each dot and understand how closely they
are related to each other and right here
we need to put in how many clusters are
we actually expecting and since we know
that the total number of the subtypes is
four and not five let's put in number
four
now do we need to transpose or not
transposition of the table means that we
flip it on its side right now our column
names are samples and our row names are
genes
if we analyze the data as is it will
produce clustering for the genes that we
have but instead we want to cluster the
samples and so that's why we need to
transpose the data so this should be
changed to true
click on save
and
and we'll name it
as it's performing clustering let's just
briefly take a look at what are some of
the other options that we have here
so first of all we talked about pca pca
is a very
useful tool for us to use but a lot of
times pca will perform differently on
data that is normalized or
non-normalized remember that we took a
data set that was already curated
somebody messed with it cleaned it up
normalized it so it's easy for us to use
in this example to learn about the
methods and what they do but if you
actually want to pre-process them we
have an additional section right here
under areas of analysis
under utilities
that can help us prepare the data
specifically for the type of analysis
that we would like to do we have
quantile normalization
badge correction missing data
approximation and other types of methods
to prepare the data for what we just did
beyond that we have different other
methods of visualization including box
plots heat maps t-sne ape and others
right so there's a lot of other options
here so typically when you go through
the project the project represents a
curated data set
that already prepares the data for
simple use
but as you go through these different
examples and you understand the logic
you will also learn about the detailed
steps to run data preparation data
wrangling and other tools and i will get
to that in just a few minutes
let's see if our clustering is done it
is
so let's take a look at the output here
again we have a number of different
useful outputs first of all we have only
the prediction of clusters that means we
can say which sample
was assigned to which cluster
the second thing is we have the full
table not only do we have the clusters
but we also can visually see all of the
gene expression values as well
and finally over here let's take a look
at this pdf it's a visual output that
will clearly show us what is the data
looking like in terms of groups
okay so let's take a look at what's
happening here
as we saw in the previous pca we have
two major groups a luminal
and right here we have all the rest
but if we look inside all of the rest we
can see that cloud and low
right here is a separate cluster
basal is a separate cluster
normal like is a separate cluster and
then here we have some outliers here we
have some samples that look differently
from the rest of their group
but here's another interesting insight
right here we have luminal as a separate
group and right here we have another
separate group of luminal
what do you think are these two luminal
groups that we found in this clustering
i'll give you a moment to paste your
answers in the chat
okay what do you think
is the reason that we see two major
groups within luminal
okay
based on distance yes
but why do you think we have two major
groups
so for those of you coming from a cancer
and oncology background you already know
that there's luminal a and luminal b
right
even though we don't have that in our
clinical annotation it is clear that
also here we see two major groups of
luminal so when oftentimes the clinical
information that we have
is based on
some specific markers
and not all of the data but if we take
all of the data into consideration we
will see that actually a more true
biological representation can come out
from mining the data okay
so another important thing that we see
is that this luminal sample is an
outlier and that means that we can
probably address this before we go into
the downstream interpretation
okay so kira thing is saying each of the
two major groups contain those that are
more closely related to each other
exactly they actually form subgroups
within this major group of the luminal
subtype okay so there are some
interesting things that we can learn
right here now as i mentioned there are
many other things that you can do with
this information now that we've
understood the data we can do multiple
things one of the things that we can do
is differential gene expression
differential gene expression
can provide us with information about
differences between two groups
okay
outliers are not necessarily wrong data
but they could be either if you can
imagine
a group of people there's always
somebody strange right in that group of
people so that strange person is an
outlier now what's wrong with that
person we can say like is that a wrong
person it's not a wrong person it's a
unique person right they're special
they're different
maybe if we want to understand the major
trends in the population that we're
studying they're not a good
representative but if we want to
understand what is wrong with that
person or how are they different we can
ask that question right so this type of
exploratory analysis is really designed
to give us insights give us new ideas
that are data driven by looking into the
data we get new ideas and now we can ask
questions
how do we ask questions well one way
that we can ask questions that we can
say let's forget about everything else
and let's compare here we have luminal a
here we have luminal b
how are they different right if we want
to analyze differences between two
groups we can use differential gene
expressions so differential gene
expression consists of several different
steps number one we have to understand
statistically significant genes that are
differentially expressed
that is done by different algorithms
like edge r and d c 2 which provide us
with essentially two important values
the significance or a p-value or an
adjusted p-value and
how much are they different between each
other which is full change
so
once we have the that information we can
then perform two additional steps
enrichment analysis or what types of
pathways and gene ontology terms are
enriched with genes that are
significantly differentially expressed
or gene set enrichment analysis which is
a similar approach that produces an
annotation of visual pathways
different types of metabolic pathways
signaling pathways to help us understand
how do those genes actually participate
in the processes that we can interpret
biologically
so the other type of a question that we
can ask is
what are the unique
genes
that have a profile or a signature
associated with a particular group and
that is called classification now
classification is very useful when we
want to train a model
make sure that it works on our test data
and then use it for big data analysis
right so for example i have
a population of patients i've studied
them and i've understood how they
respond to different treatments
i have a new patient coming in
how do i actually assign that person to
a group that i understand
one of the ways i can use
gene expression data classification and
find who he is most similar to
and another thing that we can do here is
we can do what's called feature
selection so feature selection will
allow us to select specific types
of
genes or markers
that i can use to look for
when i have a new clinical challenge
so we're not going to do this here but i
want to show you one thing that i didn't
show you up until now
in each one of our outputs okay let's
take a look at this pca
one of the outputs that i have is a
package of the r scripts that are useful
to analyze this data independently
because one of the objectives that we
have on the learn portal is not just to
tell you about what analysis you can do
and how to use the curated data sets but
it's actually to go beyond that and if
you would like to acquire the skills for
coding you would be able to do that
right here on the portal
so let's go and take a look at one of
those courses that um
that are going to be
taking this further sorry
okay right here in the search you can
type in data
science
and you will see that there are two
data science courses introduction to
data science in python an introduction
to data science in r
let's go to introduction to data science
and r and i'll briefly show you how this
works okay so this is the link
just again and paste it right here in
the chat
again every single lesson or every
single course here includes some free
lessons that you can go through
to understand how this portal works okay
today we will use
one of these free courses
called dimensionality reduction pca and
visualization
so what is principal component analysis
i've already described we can take all
of our data as you can see i have the
names of the cell lines i have the
annotation by group
then i have my data in the cells for
every gene included in this little table
this table is a small selection of genes
that we're going to quickly play around
with right here in the browser
let's go to next
to understand what pca is there's a
short video
and some code that actually explains
what are the steps that you take to go
from having that full table to running a
principal component analysis so first of
all there's a library we can load a
library that somebody wrote of a bunch
of different functions that we can use
to analyze this data
we then
can load the data giving it a name and
putting it into an object
transform or transposing our data just
like we did in excel but right here
we're doing it in
r
and then running pca now to run the
analysis is very simple all you need to
do is call a function from this library
you don't have to write the function
yourself you can just run it so let's
try and run it right here in the browser
we'll click on next
and here we have a little window that
opens up where we can run and modify
code
okay
so we have the input file
as you can see the input file is for
only 15 genes
we then define the data
we transpose the matrix
and then we run pca okay so let's run
this
okay all we needed to do is run we have
the output right here
okay
and we have a plot
and this plot shows us
multiple groups not just two but it
shows us three different groups
that
we don't know what they are right
because there is no annotation and here
we have another version again no
annotation
so one of the things that we would like
to do
is to actually run it in a way that we
can understand what's going on okay so
now we can't do that
because
this is an assignment so we learn how to
run it right here right here we need to
start thinking how do we change this to
make it work
a typical way to think about that is to
read right here and see what the problem
is
okay so what it is saying
is that just by itself this is not going
to work okay so
what is not working we need to figure
out based on what we have right here
okay so try running this code by adding
this part of the script to what is
already in the code block so here we
have something and here we need to
actually
add this
right here
okay so we need to take this
and you can see right here
there are some open parenthesis that are
not closed so we can't do that right
so we can see samples call name
expressions right here we just need to
take this
okay and
we need to
replace
all of this
okay and we do not need
so when we run this okay we have right
table so we have right here the right
table part right that we did say the pca
so right here we will write table
and
we have
plots
okay so
we can just
twice
okay
define the data
run okay we already did this
okay air running code let's figure out
what the problem is
okay file pc table
okay full table expressions
line 19
print
links okay so right here yes we need to
write in what are we lengths of
okay so this is going to be
pca runs
okay expressions t not found because we
have this and we need to actually
transpose it right
so right here
we have
the line on how to transpose it
so right here
all right
and the answer is correct correct so
with
joint efforts
we've
written everything that we need to run
it but we also
want
plot this
all right so now we also made a plot but
now we see what this plot is based on
and the plot is essentially based on a
new table that was prepared for pc1 and
pc2 right and so now that we see what
this result looks like
we can actually understand the deeper
logic behind the analysis that we are
doing we're essentially translating
this table that we started with in the
beginning of the 15 genes to another
table that has principal component 1 and
2
giving us positions on the scatter plot
now we can also perform other types of
exploration of this new object that we
created the pca object to understand
what is included inside and so here we
have the full 3d representation of this
principal component which shows us the
principal component analysis results not
only in
2d but actually in 3d
and here we can see a pretty good
separation
between
all of the different types of cancer
that we have luminal
however you can see that one of those
luminal guys is right here
right next to basil which is probably
that outlier that we saw before right
and so this shows us what is the outlier
the outlier is the one that was not like
the rest it was a little bit out from
the rest outlier close to another types
of cell lines okay
so
after this
we can see some additional code and we
can go through step by step
to really understand more and more how
do we take this basic script that we
learn how it works
and finally
produce a plot that we can understand
with annotation for groups even with
deaf defined groups that now are
according to the classes that we have
and that is all really the objective of
the omics logic portal the omics logic
portal connects the logical analysis of
complex omics data
with case studies where you can
understand the relevance the need and
the outputs of different types of
analyses you can choose to go deeper and
understand the analysis details and
syntax of coding
or you can also join a program
that will
be mentor guided
and someone like what we did today we'll
just go through
some of the examples that we are having
and those examples will be used uh too
okay let's go back to programs
um and those examples will be
used to
explain some of these concepts in a more
guided way
so all of this information is linked
together under my personal profile and
this is an important part of this portal
is that all of the activity that i just
did as you can see i've completed
modeling precision medicine publication
i've completed the step biological
concept of precision medicine learn
right so every step that i take
accumulates into a number of points
that overall take me from a beginner to
an intermediate level
to an expert
once i cross
the 10 000 point threshold i will be
able to
design an independent project
an independent project
is essentially a publication
that i can design to showcase what i
have learned and take a data set of my
own applying the skills that i've
acquired during the training
and showing what it is that i have
learned now here are some example
projects that other people have
completed during the training
and once you complete a project
we are excited to
show how you can use the experience and
the projects that you have created to
essentially move forward in your career
and so now briefly let me introduce you
to the omix research symposium that we
are planning
to um start
august 21st and 27th okay we already
have
over 1500 participants that have
registered for the workshop or sorry for
the symposium it will be a two-day
symposium where we will have
experts in the field of bioinformatics
coming from academic programs around the
world
speaking about the need and the
challenges and opportunities in
bioinformatics and the need for training
and in the second day
providing you with some insights on how
to get involved how do you get involved
you can present
your project and get feedback from
experts
you can learn about academic programs
for undergraduates high school students
undergraduates graduates
you can also understand how to
participate in a research fellowship
program that will help you design and
complete a project in a short period of
time between three and six months
now at the same time you will also learn
about
different companies
that are hiring for bioinformatics
skills in africa
in india
in the us and around the world and we'll
have some experts from pharmaceutical
biotechnology companies and
bioinformatics companies
that will explain what they're looking
for and how to get involved in what they
are doing
yes students from non-biology background
can attend the symposium the symposium
is open for everyone who is interested
in bioinformatics as a researcher
as a student as an expert as an uh
industry professional so down here at
the bottom you will find a short video
that describes what the symposium is all
about and to summarize and kind of share
with you the details of the registration
and the schedule
i will pass it on to dr mohit mazumdar
who will be
one of the people
organizing some of the panel discussions
are you there
okay i don't i think soda is facing some
networking issue
okay so america maybe you could just
take everybody through the
schedule to explain
what is going to happen during the
symposium
yes sure
just a second let me just pull out the
page
[Music]
so while i'm just pulling out the page
it would be great to know about you all
you can let us know about your research
background and what is your research
interest and so this topic today was
bioinformatics for non-bioinformation
so hoping that you all are from a
non-bioinformatics background we would
love to know how come you are inclined
towards uh
getting acquainted with bioinformatics
and what sort of purpose you had
attending the workshop today and what do
you foresee yourself in in future
okay so talking about the schedule of
the symposium we have great speakers who
would be talking about
the area of their expertise
and the symposium is on august 21st and
22nd as india has already told us i
would be sharing the link with you in
the chat box and also i would be
marrying all the details with you all uh
on the mail after the workshop is over
here is the schedule link
so uh we would be uh beginning with a
talk uh uh with dr gps siragawa and he's
a head and professor at triple iet delhi
and then uh we'll have a talk on
industry driven education and health
care in india by professor palu radhana
and uh having a short break then we will
we also have a
a team in
africa whom we call as omixlogic africa
or eureka so we'll be having some
opening remarks by them as well and we
have great projects on which the our
africa team has already worked on and we
would be having their presentations as
well and then we would be having a talk
by dr anita ghansa on bioinformatics of
infectious disease and relevance to
public health and
then ilya would be giving an opening
ceremony and uh topics telling us all
about what we would be going ahead with
followed by a panel discussion where we
will be having dr gus dr leonard brodsky
professor sona vasudevan from joshua
medical
georgetown medical university
professor palu radar and dr gps ragwa
again and now what we have done is we
have your breakout rooms so in the
breakout rooms we would be having uh
talks going on
in different sorts of fields so let's
say if you are interested in uh
artificial intelligence or machine
learning you could be
in one breakout room or if you're
interested to learn more about
astrobiology that's an emerging field
and we have a lot of projects on that as
well and our research fellows are
working on it too and then we have a
field as agribio informatics as well so
these are different sorts of feel you
can be a part of and join the breakout
rooms
depending on your research interest you
can find the details of all the speakers
who would be
talking about these different sorts of
fields and giving their talk
on their
expert topics
and then comes the uh second day where
we would be having talks by uh
professor seema professor sona and dr
philip compu and we have the details and
the topics of their talks already
mentioned in this uh schedule page i
would love if you could go along with me
through this uh schedule page itself and
learn more about what all talks you are
going to have so you see it's really
actually uh actually because of kobe
this thing
is in our favor that we are getting to
meet
uh like great personalities with such
great experience and expertise and talk
to them we can discuss
our research idea as well with them and
in the break sessions obviously we we
can listen to what's actually going
around and happening around in the world
what's significant and how how can we
proceed and make a career in that
particular
research area and then we would be
having a talk by dr shindo hicks and uh
so i'm just getting a pop-up as
participants can now see my screen i
just want to confirm if you all uh were
able to see my screen before as well
yes yes it was visible okay okay thank
you
and then we have a talk by dr chris
taylor on bioinformatics biostatistics
and computational biology so
in my master's actually i was told that
biostatistics
is going to become a very emerging field
uh with great career opportunities so
now what happens with us when we are in
our final year we definitely start
thinking about what are the future
opportunities what uh and the field in
which we are working will we get a
stable job or not because after covering
people are facing recession right and
bioinformatics biostatistics and
computational biology these three fields
remain those fields which are
evolving so much day by day and these
three fields are not going to face any
sort of issues and we speed obviously
you can see that you can just sit at
your home uh at your own comfort and be
a part of such great research around and
uh the server specially you need not
have uh specialized laptops or pcs or
systems and still you can work on your
data and get your results and publish a
paper just sitting at your home so that
is the beauty of bioinformatics and
computational biology actually
and then we have a talk by dr uh shamir
khadr he's
and he would be uh
like
giving a talk definitely and then he
would be guiding us as well through what
all uh like a company looks at while
hiring people so job opportunities are
the like one of the best things that we
are going to discuss about in the
symposium and also the career related
opportunities what a bachelor student
should go ahead with or a master's
student should go ahead with and what
exact skill set a company looks at while
hiring candidates that's a very big
question so that so in that particular
direction we can um
like have an expertise and create our
skill set
etc etc and then we'll have a panel
discussion by our panelists and
then the poster presentation which is on
on 21st that would be followed by
the panel discussion and the winners
would be announced on 22nd
and that's it
so now please let me know in the chat
box what are doubts you have
and also i would love to know from
what all fields you are and what is your
research and trust
you can simply unmute yourself and we
can have a word
okay so hoping that we have no doubts uh
here
now after the workshop i would be
sending you out the guidelines to
register yourself for the symposium
because i feel that it's very important
that you all can definitely make uh
like make your weekends work well for
you by being a part of such wonderful
talks and the symposium has got three
categories so the first category is for
the free listeners the free listeners
can like uh simply join the symposium
they need not register anywhere and
those who are entrusted to present their
research work in the as a poster
presentation in the symposium they need
to register as dollar ten now why we
have this particular registration fee as
dollar 10 is just because we have uh
various prices that would be given out
to the winners of the poster
presentation and
also those who want to be a part of
their workshops that would be there
ahead of the symposium and also get the
basic membership of the omixlogic loan
portal they have to go ahead with the
registration fee of dollar 15. i would
be sharing the registration page as well
with you all and also those um schedule
of the symposium and the registration
page of the symposium now if you have
any doubts
you can mail me at support other pine
dot bio
or you can also reach out to our
marketing team at marketing at the rate
omixlogic.com or marketing at the
ratepine.bio
thank you so has for letting us know
about your research and trust
and uh i will also be giving out a
feedback form and it would be great if
you could fill it out for us and let us
know uh about what you feel about the
workshop and was your motive
accomplished or not thank you everyone
for joining we'll be looking forward to
meeting you all on in the symposium on
21st and 22nd of august
take care till then bye